The Divine Comedy
is the greatest literary masterpiece in
human history. When Dante wrote it in
about 1300, he called it LaMada.
Okay.
And the reason why is that at this time
in history, epic poetry was considered
high, okay, or tragic.
And it was written usually in Latin.
But for Dante, what he really believed
is that epic poetry should be
democratic. It should be accessible to
the people. That's why he called it
laadia low. Okay.
Which meant comedy and so he wrote it in
Tuskin which is the language of Florence
where he lived.
Um Latin was the language of the elite
in Europe. He wanted to write in Tuskin
so that ordinary people around him could
access it. And as a result, Dante is
a great believer in democracy. So, uh,
Homer,
Dante
and Shakespeare
were in their own respective languages
the greatest poets because first and
foremost they believe that poetry
should be accessed by the people. They
believed in um a democratic spirit to
poetry and that made them distinct from
the people of their time.
Lamadia is response then to the Iniad by
Virgil.
At this time in history, for the past
1,000 years, the INAD was a dominant
dominant literature in Europe and it was
the foundation for the Catholic Church.
Okay. So remember when we read the iniad
the end is fundamentally about duty
uh piety
um and it just spokes and it contrasted
love.
Okay. And this became the dominant idea
in the Catholic Church where
you are not allowed to access God.
You're not allowed to believe in love.
You must obey the church because only
the church can guarantee you redemption
and salvation. And this of course led to
massive corruption in the Catholic
Church. But it also led to wars
throughout Europe because so much power
was concentrated in the Catholic Church
and as a result many kings fought over
um for power in the Catholic Church and
this led to many wars. It led also to a
splintering of the Catholic Church and
Dante found himself embroiled into a lot
of these conflicts. Okay. So he wrote La
Kamadia in order to have people access
God. Okay, through the for the comedy
you can access God and bypass Catholic
Church. In fact, if you read Lamadia,
you'll find there are a lot of direct
criticisms of the Catholic Church. Also,
Lcomadia was written in response to the
Iniad. And like Homer, what Dante wants
to do is position love first and
foremost. Okay. In Lamadia, love is God
itself. All right. So these are the
basic themes that we'll be looking at um
throughout this book. So let me talk
about the structure of Laka Laadia,
right? There are three distinct parts.
First is inferno.
Second is purgatory.
And the last is paradise.
And what makes um the laamadia
so powerful is Dante uses two major lit
literary devices to construct his
universe. The first is what we call
structure.
The second is paradox.
All right.
So imagine laadia as not just epic
poetry but as a very complex
mathematical puzzle that you must
unravel through time. Okay. So um
inferno the structure is an inverted
triangle. And so what's going to happen
is that Dante and Virgil are going to um
tra uh travel through inferno through
hell. But it's almost like they're
traveling underground. Okay? It's an
inverted triangle. And then purgatory
becomes a pyramid or a mountain where
Dante and Virgil are going to travel up
a mountain so that they can meet Beatric
at the very top. And why they will meet
Beatric at the very top is that Beatrice
will take um Dante to heaven where he
will meet God. And that is the very
ending of the divine comedy. Okay.
Laadia. And in paradise it is structured
as
um a
solar system.
And here is something called the
imperium where God is and then Dante
will travel with Beatrice into the
imperium and it's structured like a uh
solar system. Okay. So that's a very
structure of the divine comedy and as
you can see it's very mathematical.
It's rigorous if it's mathematical.
There's a symmetry to the the lam idea
doesn't really exist anywhere else in
poetry. But what makes divine comedy so
distinct and so powerful is the idea of
paradox or maybe dissonance.
cognitive dissonance.
And so
all poetry is designed to be memorized.
It's all designed to be read aloud. And
there are subtlety and nuance in all
poetry. And the reason why is think of
poetry as almost like a virus. And what
it what it's trying to do is it's trying
to infiltrate you. It's trying to
subvert you. And it's trying to remake
you. Okay? And that's what divine comedy
does where you read it and it all sounds
very simple and nice but the more you
memorize it the more you interact with
it the more it enters you and it creates
cognitive dissonance meaning that it is
disrupting the normal way you see the
world. It creates paradox and what's
going to happen is that your mind is
going to by itself subconsciously try to
unravel these paradoxes over time.
Okay. So the more you read the divine
comedy over decades, the more it will
reveal itself to you.
It is a universe that comes into you and
then it remakes you. Okay? And that is
the power and beauty of the divine
comedy. So the trick is to unravel the
paradoxes
uh which will implant themselves
throughout the divine comedy. Okay. So
what um so another thing about the
structure is that in order to reach
paradise Dante must first enter inferno.
Okay. And there are different ways you
can interpret the meaning of this. The
simplest way to interpret this is that
in order to really truly discover God,
you must experience hell yourself. Okay?
So good and evil are
um
are intertwined together. You can never
have good unless you first experience
evil. Good is not the absence of evil.
Good is a confrontation and the defeat
of evil. Okay, that's one possible way
to interpret it. Another way to
interpret interpret it is that inferno
represents Virgil
uh which represents the iniad.
And so for Dante to begin the process of
entering into heaven, he must first
recognize the impact of Virgil and the
Iniad on his psyche, on his culture, and
then by recognizing this defeat the
Iniad in order to fully embrace uh the
power of God and of love. Okay? And and
that's the interpretation that I want I
want I want to present to you as we go
along. All right? Okay.
So, um having gone that let's go over
some basic biography. Uh this is Dante
and Dante is considered the greatest
poet in the Italian in Italian language.
At this time in history, Italy was
divided into city states. So, um Dante
was in Florence, but there are also some
major city states like Venice and
Genanoa.
Okay? And they're all competing against
each other. They were also competing
against Rome,
okay, the Catholic Church,
which wanted to exert authority over
these city states. At the same time, you
had uh the different empires of Europe,
for example, France
and basically the Holy Roman Empire,
which we would today call Germany.
and they're also trying to exert
authority over uh these city states. At
the same time, there are different
factions within these state city states,
different families that fight against
each other. So during Dante's time and
this this again is about the year 1300
he is experiencing constant conflict,
constant violence, constant hatred. And
for him the major question is how can we
as a people as humans escape this
constant cycle of vengeance and hatred
and war and that's why he wrote the
divine comedy. Um two major bio
biographic details that you need to
understand about him is that he is of
noble birth and therefore he's a
participant in
uh this conflict. So uh the northern
Italian city states which include
Florence, Milan, um uh Genanoa and
Venice, they have two major political
factions. Okay, this is Wikipedia by the
way. All right. Uh the Gves which
support the Papacy and the Giblins who
support the Holy Roman Empire. Okay. So
Donny's family belongs to the Gves. So
he was just born into this political
rivalry and over time what will happen
is that the GS will win but then the GS
will divide into the black and white uh
factions. So different families fighting
for power again. Okay. So for Dante all
his life he's experienced nothing but
political rivalry and hatred. That's the
first major thing you need to know about
him. Ultimately what will happen is that
he'll get sick of this um constant
fighting and he will exile himself to
focus on his poetry. The other thing to
know about him is he falls in love with
Beatrice at a very early age. Okay. Um
he meets her when she is nine and she is
eight. The problem is that Beatric's
family is of more noble aristocratic
birth than Dante. And at this time in
history all marriages are arranged. And
so Dante marries someone of his class.
Beatrice marries someone of of his
class, but they never really um
abandon each other. Okay. They they
still remain friends. And Dante in his
heart still has this longing for
Beatrice. Beatrice will die pretty
young. Maybe when she's in her mid20s,
she'll die giving birth. But Dante never
for forgets about her. And he spends his
entire life still remembering his love
for Dante, for Beatrice. And this
becomes the basis of the divine comedy.
Okay. Lama.
Um so these are the two major biograph
biographical details you need to know
about Dante.
Okay. So um again this is um um
from Wikipedia. And when Dante is exiled
from Florence, okay, he never returns to
Florence. He spends all his life in
exile. he becomes patronized by some
very powerful aristocrats throughout um
Italy and he will spend his a lot of his
time reflecting on his experience in
this political faction. In the divine
comedy there'll be a lot of references
to this conflict between the Giblings
and the Gves and his exile from Florence
and his hatred of the Catholic Church.
Um there will also be a lot of
references to his love for Beatatrice
which will redeem him from this earthly
conflict. Okay. All right. So some
passages that we've looked at um before
but which I want us to emphasize. Okay.
To truly understand divine comedy. All
right. So let's look at certain
passages. Okay. So um uh Aubrey could
you read for me please?
When I had dream half of our life's way,
I found myself within a shadowed forest,
for I had lost a path that does not
stray.
Uh, it is hard to speak of what it was,
that savage forest, dense and difficult,
which even in recall renews my fear, so
bitter death is hardly more severe. But
to retell the good discovered there,
I'll also tell the other things I saw.
Okay. So he's singing right this is very
beginning of the divine comedy. This is
the Alan Madam bomb translation. Okay.
And I choose Alan Madam Bombal. There
are lots of um other
um translations because he's just the
easiest to read. All right. So I'm not
I'm I'm not interested in the language.
I'm interested in the ideas. So that's
why I pick him. Okay. So this is very
simple. He is in middle age and he's in
a shadow forest. Okay. So, he's simply
confused
um as to why the world is what it is.
This hatred for the world is um causing
him to hate himself as well. And so,
because of this hatred, because of this
confusion about why there's so much
hatred in the world, he has lost his
connection with God. Um and he doesn't
know how to proceed. It's a long period
of savage forest dancing difficult that
makes him question everything. Okay,
he's in a deep depression basically and
and at this point he is lost in this
forest and he feels hopeless. And then a
man emerges named Virgil.
And Virgil is the poet that Dante
respects the most because at this point
in history, Virgil is the most
influential poet. And Virgil promises to
guide Dante out of this shadow forest
and into the light. And Dante puts his
faith in Virgil. And at this point,
Dante sees Virgil not just as a savior,
but as a father and as a teacher. Okay,
this is important because for Dante to
truly defeat Virgil, which is the point
of the commodia, he wants to destroy the
influence and power of the Iniad, he
first must put Virgil onto a pedest
pedestal in order for us to recognize
the limitations of Virgil so that we
ourselves can defeat Virgil in our
hearts. Okay. And that's the idea here.
All right. Uh can can you continue? Uh,
ivory.
All right. Yep. Keep on going.
>> In heaven, there's a gentle lady, one
who weeps for the distress towards which
I send you to. So that stern judgment up
above is shattered. And it was she who
called upon Lucia, requesting of her.
Now your faithful one is need of you.
And I commend him to you. Lucia, enemy
of every cruelty, arose and made her way
to where I was, sitting beside the
venerable Rachel. She said, "You,
Beatatrice, true praise of God, why have
you not helped him when who loves you so
that for your sake he slept a vulgar
crowd? Do you not hear the anguish in
his cry? Do you not see the death he
wars against upon that river ruthless as
to see? No one within this world has
ever been so quick to seek his good or
flee his harm as I when she had finished
speaking thus to come below down from my
blessed station. I trusted in your
honest utterance which honors you and
those who have listened to you. When she
had finished with her words to me, she
turned aside her gleaming tearful eyes
which only made me hurry all the more.
>> Okay, so a lot of laadia divine comedy
is dialogue. Okay, there's a speaker and
there's a listener.
And
this is an important formulation
uh because what Dante wants us is to
recognize is that when a speaker speaks,
he or she is speaking from a certain
worldview, a certain prejudice. And so
we must always be on guard. We we almost
always ask ourselves why this person is
saying what he or she is saying. Okay.
So um something that we discuss a lot is
the idea of God. Okay. And God is the
perfect manifestation of love of
generosity of forgiveness.
And one thing that God does not do is
reciprocity.
Okay.
So the Catholic Church teaches you that
if you obey God, then God will allow you
access to heaven. And what Donnie wants
us to understand is that's cannot be
true. If God is perfection, if God is
love, if God is beauty, God would never
require anything of you. God will always
give you free will.
And free will and reciprocity are
contradiction.
Okay. If I make you do something in
order to access heaven, that means I
don't give you free will. But God
will give you free will. All right? But
here we can see a contradiction, a
paradox in that what? So what's
happening is that Dante is talking to
Virgil and Don is asking Virgil, "How
did you get here? Why are you here? Why
are you taking me to um heaven?" And
Virgil's response is, "Well, I was
having a very nice time sitting in uh
home in limbo in hell. But then an
angel, Beatus, came to me and said she
need my help in order to help a friend."
And then Donnie is like, "Okay, but why
would Beatress want to help me?" And
then Virgil was like, "Well, because she
saw your pain in in heaven and she
recognizes
how much you love her." And so, um,
Lucia said to her, "You, Beatatrice, why
don't you help him who loves you so
much?"
Okay. So it's almost like a a a
reciprocity where because Donnie loves
Beatric so much, Beatrice has to come
help him now.
But this goes against the very idea of
God. Okay. So what's happening here is
two possibilities. The first possibility
is that Virgil is just lying.
Okay? But he's not really lying. He's
just mis he's just misinterpreting
what's going on.
God will always come to you if you truly
want God to come.
Okay? Because God is all generous. And
so Dante is his heart is calling out for
God. And God sends Beatrice without any
conditions.
And God sends Beatric because God
understands that Beatrice is a person
who can most help Dante. Okay? There's
no reciprocity here. But when Beatrice
tells Virgil this. Virgil misinterprets
this idea to mean that there's
reciprocity going on. Okay. So, that's
not it's not really lying, but it shows
you the limitations
of Virgil's worldview where in the INIA
it's all about reciprocity. Okay? It's
all about contract. It's all about duty.
Okay? So, that's the first possibility.
But another possibility is that Beatrice
understands the limitations of Virgil
and so just tells Virgil what he wants
to hear or structures this in a way that
Virgil can understand. Okay? Because if
Peter says to uh Virgil, I came to help
Dante because
uh Dante needs help.
Virgil will be like, well, okay, he
needs help, but why help him? And so
Beatri doesn't want to spend time
explaining to him that the universe is
all forgiven. Uh so so she just says,
"Okay, well, it's because he helped me
in the past. It's because of his love
for me that I'm able to go to heaven."
Okay.
All right. So already in the beginning
we have to question the authority of
Virgil. Okay. Virgil is an unreliable
God.
And for us to truly enter paradise, for
us to truly discover God, we need to
recognize he is unreliable ourselves.
Not only will never tell us, but he'll
give us clues to suggest that he is
unreliable. And we must reject him if we
are to fully embrace God. Okay.
All right. Let's continue. All right.
All right. So, Virgil is taking Dante
into hell. And Virgil emphasizes Dante,
this is a path that we must take if we
are to go into paradise. You must first
confront evil. You must first understand
sin for you to truly understand
goodness. Okay? All right. And so when
they get there, there's a river that
blocks their path into hell. And there
is a fairy man named Cheron from Greek
mythology who will take them across the
um river. But the problem is that Dante
is still living. And Cheron sees that
and he says to Dante, "Uh, there's a
problem here. I can't take your cross
because you're a living soul and you're
not dead. So I can't give you access to
um hell. Okay. All right. Can you read
Ivory?
>> And here advancing towards us in a boat,
an aged man. His his hair was white with
ears was shouting, "Woe to you corrupted
souls. Forget your hope of ever seeing
heaven. I come to lead you to the other
shore, to the eternal dark, to fire and
frost. and you approaching there, you
living soul, keep well away from these,
they are the dead." But when he saw I
made no move to go, he said, "Another
way in other harbors, not here, will
bring you passage to your shore. A
lighter craft will have to carry you. My
guide then, Sharon, don't torment
yourself. Our passage has been willed
above, where one can do what he has
willed, and ask no more." Now silence
fell upon the woolly cheeks of Sharon.
pilots of the Livid Marsh whose eyes
were ringed about with wheels of flame.
>> Okay, so Sharon doesn't want to take
Dante across because Dante is still
living. Um, but when Virgil says to him,
"Hey, let us pass." Sharon uh obeys.
Okay? And this is a paradox. So, let me
explain the paradox to you. Again, the
thing about Dante is that he's so subtle
and it's written in a perfect manner. So
the more you try to understand what's
going on, the more truth will be
revealed to you. So the paradox is this.
They are in hell and they are in hell
because they've rejected God. Okay? And
the re and how we know they rejected God
is this sentence. Woe to you corrupted
souls. Forget your hope of ever seeing
heaven. Okay? So so you can interpret
this as saying that Sharon is saying to
you is saying to people this is all
hopeless. Okay. But another way of
interpreting this is Sharon Sharon is
saying to all these souls, you are here
because you believe God has abandoned
you. You believe there is no God. You
believe there's no heaven. You believe
you deserve to be here. That's why
you're here. Okay.
Um so that but then he sees Dante and he
he knows that Dante doesn't believe
this. He is actually going to heaven.
And so Dante is a corruption. And so
Shiron doesn't want to take Dante
across. But then Virgil says, "Hey, God
has ordered
Dante to be crossed." And then Sharon
obeys. The problem, the paradox is this.
Sharon himself doesn't believe in God.
That's why he's in hell. He rejects the
authority of God. Yet he obeys God. So
that makes absolutely no sense. This is
a paradox.
Unless you remember that what matters is
the speaker. Okay. So Virgil is the one
who is speaking. Okay. So in other
words, Sheron is not obeying the
authority of God. He's obeying the
authority of the speaker who is Virgil.
And this suggests to us that Virgil is
the master of hell.
And the question then is well why is he
master of hell and the answer is because
he created hell through the iniad right
iniad is a poetry that emphasizes piety
obedience. It emphasizes
how love is a disease. It emphasizes the
the importance of hatred as a power to
show your enemies. It emphasizes empire.
So in other words, Virgil through the
Iniad created emotions in human be in
human beings that allow for the creation
of hell itself. You can also argue that
with the INiD virs for the Catholic
Church. The Catholic Church is not based
on the Bible. It's based on the Iniad.
Okay. So again this is not apparent
um in the poetry but once you understand
that
um Dante is conveying his truth through
paradox and you try to unravel this
paradox then the truth slowly reveals
itself to you. Okay.
All right. Let's continue.
All right. Can you read me? He start
>> the demon Sharon with his eyes like
embers by signaling to them has all
embarked. His aura strikes any anyone
who stretches out as in the autumn
leaves detach themselves first one and
then the other till the bow sees all his
fallen garments on the ground.
Similarly, the evil seed of Adam
descended from the shoreline one by one
when signaled as the fall gun called
will come. So do they move across the
darkened waters even before they reach
farther shore? New ranks already gather
on this bank. My son, the gracious
master said to me, those who have died
beneath the wrath of God. All these
assemble here from every country, and
they are eager for the river crossing
because celestial justice spurs them on
so that their fears turn into desire. No
good soul ever takes this passage
passage here. Therefore, if Sharon has
complained of you, by now you can be
sure what his words mean.
>> Okay? So, two words that you will see a
lot in Dante are will and desire. Okay?
Will and desire because will and desire
together create your soul. Okay? So, in
divine comedy, you will see these two
words will and desire repeated a lot.
You are what you want and what you move
towards. Okay, that's ultimately your
soul. And um what this is telling us is
that people are evil because people
obey.
Okay, duty.
Okay, so
this image is where the people line up
obediently and do as they're told. They
don't question why this is happening.
They don't resist why this is happening.
Okay. Their will and desire is to move
towards hell. They are not in hell
because they did bad things. Everyone
does bad things. They're in hell.
They're in hell because they desire to
be in hell. Okay? And it's something
that Virgil says.
Their fear is turned into desire.
They're entering hell because they want
to do so. And this is a really important
idea if you are to understand Dante.
Free will is a fundamental truth of the
universe. You do what you do because you
choose to do it. You're in hell not
because you did bad things. You are in
hell because you think that hell is a
best place for you. You're happy in
hell. Okay.
All right. So now they are in hell and
the first place that they enter is
something called limbo. And limbo is a
place where people go. They're good
people. The but the problem is they
don't believe in Jesus. They don't
believe in Christ. They never convert to
Christianity. So these are people like
Virgil, like Homer, like Plato, okay?
Very virtuous people. But unfortunately
they um don't believe in God and so
therefore they are doomed in hell or
that's what Virgil tells Dante. Donnie
is suspicious and and Donnie asks Virgil
was there ever a time when people in
hell could ascend to heaven. And Virgil
says there was only one time and that
was when Jesus died and he came to hell
to save and redeem those most worthy.
People like King David, people like
Noah, people like Abraham, people like
Rachel who are in the Bible who are born
before the time of Christ but who are
worthy of going to heaven and that's why
Jesus came to hell. Unfortunately, I
Virgil
came after
uh Jesus and so I was not safe by by
him. Okay? And as you go on, you I would
remember this because what we'll
discover as we go on is this is not
true. It is entirely possible for people
who were not Christians,
who were born before the time of Jesus
to ascend to heaven because they choose
to. It's about will and desire. Okay? So
um and then they go into the first layer
of hell. And the first layer of hell are
people who lust. Okay? These are people
whose passion
overrided their reason and so they um
sinned. Okay. All right. Okay. Uh and so
these are spirits that are passing
through and Donnie asked Virgil, "Who
are these people?" And Virgil starts to
name them one by one. Okay. Okay. Can
you read um Ivory?
>> The kindly master said, "Do you not ask
who are these spirits whom you see
before you? I'd have you know before you
go ahead they did not sin and yet though
they have merits that's not enough
because they lacked baptism the portal
of faith that you embrace and if they
lived before Christianity they did not
worship God in fitting ways and of such
spirits I myself am one for these
defects and for no other evil we now are
lost and punished just with this we have
no hope and yet we live in longing great
sorrow sees my heart on hearing him for
I seen some inestimable men among the
souls suspended in that limbo.
>> Okay, so I want you to remember this
passage because Virgil is saying there's
nothing wrong with me. Unfortunately, I
I was just unlucky. Okay, this is this
is incorrect. What you will see as we
move on is that Virgil chooses to be
here. There are many paths for salvation
reduction for him. He but he wants to
stay in hell. Okay.
>> And why and why that is the case, we'll
we'll we'll talk about later. All right,
let's keep on going.
>> So I descended from the first enclosure
down to the second circle. That which
girdles less space but grief more great
that goes to weeping.
There dreadful Mino stands nashing his
teeth examining the sins of those who
enter. He judges and assigns all as his
as his tail of twines. I mean that when
the spirit born to evil appears before
him, it confesses all and he the
connoisseur of sin can tell the death
and hell appropriate to it. As many
times as Minos wraps his tail around
himself that marks the sinner's level.
Always there is a crowd that stands
before him. Each soul in turns advances
towards the judgment. They speak in here
then they are cast below. Arresting his
extraordinary task, Minos, as soon as he
had seen me, said, "Oh, you who reached
this house of suffering, be careful how
you enter, whom you trust. The gate is
wide, but do not be deceived." To which
my guide replied, "But why protest? Do
not attempt to block his faded path. Our
passage has been willed above, where one
can do what he has willed and ask no
more." Okay, so this is a very
interesting passage that again
um makes us question things. Okay, so
Minos who's basically deciding which uh
level of hell you go to based on your
sin, he basically says to Dante, don't
trust anyone here. Okay, don't trust
anyone here. Be be careful how you enter
whom you trust. The gate is wide, but do
not be deceived.
Okay, this is a very strange
idea, right? Because Minos sees that
Dante is with Virgil.
And his response is, Dante, you're a
good person. I'm telling you right now,
don't trust anyone. Right? So, what he's
really saying is, Dante, don't trust
Virgil. Right? If you think about it
logically, makes no sense for him to say
that unless he means don't trust Virgil.
Because if Virgil can be trusted, then
all Donnie has to do is just follow
Virgil into hell and that's it. Okay?
But Minnows makes a point of saying
don't trust anyone here. Which is to
say, don't trust the person closest to
you. Be careful how you enter and whom
you trust. Okay. And what confirms this
is
to which my guy replied, but why
protest? Okay. So Virgil is jumping in
right and said, "Hey, shut up, man."
Okay.
Do not attempt to block his faded path.
Our past has been willed above where one
can do what he has willed and ask no
more. We are I represent a higher power
than you know.
All right. So again, this is questioning
the reliability of narrator. What's
happening is that Dante is planting
seeds, giving us clues that in hell
nothing is what it seems.
The person that we most trust, Virgil,
is the person we should probably least
trust. Okay.
All right. So, everything that Virgil
says, we have to question.
All right. So, again, um Virgil and
Dante are in the first layer of hell.
This is lust and Virgil is pointing out
to Dante who they are. Okay. Can can you
read uh uh Ivory?
>> The first of those about whose history
you want to know. My master then told me
once ruled as empress over many nations.
Her vice of lust became so customary
that she made license in her laws to
free her from the scandal she had
caused. She is Simis of whom we read
that she was Ningus' wife and his
successor.
She held the land the sultan now
commands. That other spirit killed
herself for love and she and she
betrayed the ashes of Sakiius, the
wanting Cleopatra follows next. See
Helen, whose sake so many years for
whose sake so many years of evil had to
pass. See great Achilles, who finally
met love in his last battle. See Paris,
Tristan, and he points out a name to me
more than a thousand shades departed
from our life because of love. No sooner
had I heard my teacher name the ancient
ladies and the knights than pity seized
me and I was like a man astray.
>> Okay, so this again is a paradox. Okay,
and again it's almost impossible to see
this paradox by yourself.
But the paradox is this
um what Virgil will do is basically
point out a thousand shades. Okay, he'll
provide all the names of these people.
Okay, an example is um Simz
um and then you have Cleopatra, you have
Helen, you have Achilles, you have
Paris, you have Trist. Okay, so he's
naming everyone but there's one shade he
does not name.
And the other spirit who killed herself
for love and she betrayed the ashes of
Sakius. We know who this person is
because this person is Ditto. And who is
Ditto?
Ditto is the creation of Virgil.
So the grand paradox, the irony is
there's a thousand people and the person
that Virgil refuses to acknowledge by
name is the one that he understands the
best, who he is most intimate with.
Okay. And this creates the question, why
is this the case? Why does he refuse to
name Ditto? So if you go back to the um
Iniad, the one thing that stands out
about the Iniad is that Ditto is the
most realistic character. It's really
the character that most people when they
read the Iniad, they sympathize with
because Ditto feels real, but at the
same time, Ditto didn't really deserve
her fate. Okay? So, it is Virgil
who cast Ditto into hell, right? And
this contrast with Dante who will
elevate
Beatatrice his love to heaven.
All right. So already we are seeing a
contrast a paradox. Okay. Virgil
condemned Ditto to hell. Dante elevated
Beatrice to heaven. And Dante is longing
for Beatatrice. And then Virgil forgets
that Ditto even existed. He even refuses
to name her. Okay. And the question is
is why? So because Ditto is a real
estate character, we can assume that
Ditto is based on a person that Virgil
knows. But not only that, we can also
make the assumption that Virgil pursued
Ditto, fell in love with Ditto, and
Ditto rejected him probably because he
was an ugly Okay. And so Virgil
got really angry and decided that I will
condemn Ditto to hell. But in his heart,
Virgil knows that this was unfair, that
this was pure hatred.
And so he feels a bit guilty about, he
feels embarrassed about it. That's why
he refuses to acknowledge Ditto. He
refuses to face Ditto uh for um what he
did. Okay. But then something
interesting happens. All right.
Okay.
Can you read um
my first words? Poet, I should willingly
speak with those two who go together
there and seem so lightly carried by the
wind. And he to me, you'll see when they
draw closer to us, and then you may
appeal to them by that love which impels
them. They will come. No sooner had the
wind bent them towards us than I urged
on my voice. Oh battered souls, if one
does not forbid it, speak with us. Even
as doves, when summoned by desire, born
forward by their will, move through the
air with wings up uplifted. Still to
their sweet nest, those spirits left the
ranks where ditto sufferers approaching
us through the milant air. So powerful
had been my loving cry. Okay. So, what
he's saying here is that like Virgil is
naming all all the shades and Donnie is
like, "Let me go and talk to them." And
Virgil says, "Sure, go talk to him."
Okay. But what I want you to notice is
this. Those spirits left the ranks where
Ditto suffers approaching us through the
magnet ear. Okay? So, the contrast is
this.
Virgil refuses to name Ditto. So Dante
names Ditto himself.
All right. And what this what this
really is is an act of rebellion
because
Donnie acknowledges Virgil as his
father, as his guide, as his teacher.
And therefore, he should just follow
Virgil. If Virgil doesn't want to name
Ditto, doesn't want to acknowledge
Ditto, then Donnie should be respectful
and ignore Ditto, right? But he's
saying, "Nope, I'm going to name Ditto
because I I want us to understand that
it was wrong to not acknowledge Ditto.
It was wrong, first of all, for Virgil
to condemn Ditto to hell, and it's wrong
to just ignore her." Okay, so I know who
Ditto is. I know what Virgil did and I
want to name her in order to resurrect
her in our memory. All right. So again,
this is creating cognitive dissonance.
It's leaving an idea in our heads that
none of what we're seeing in inferno is
what it seems. That's why it's hell
because it's all an illusion. It's all
deception. And we have to use our minds.
We have to use our hearts to truly
understand what's going on. Okay. All
right. So, this begins our journey into
the line comedy. But as you can see, it
is extremely complex. You have to see
with your heart. You have to see with
your imagination. It's impossible to
just read this and know what's going on.
You have to
believe in your instincts. You have to
believe in your intuition. You have to
believe that you have connection with
God. And it is God that will reveal to
you the truth through your intuition and
your imagination. Okay. So the divine
colony is a journey really into your own
heart and your faith. All right. Any
questions?
Okay. All right. So we will continue
this next time. Okay.